[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon
what's up fam what's up thicker stick of
Tears figurines it's almost Halloween's
I thought that was gonna rhyme about to
put an ass on Halloween God damn it so
we start off Monday what's up fam how's
everybody doing hopefully I hope you had
a good weekend it is Monday October 10th
coming in hot coming in thick Cheers
Cheers 9 A.M chance drinking just a
little hung over huh yeah I don't know
if uh the fans if you haven't seen it
yet chin was hanging out with the my
good buddy jelly roll jelly roll likes a
drink here's the thing about jelly roll
not only does jelly roll like to drink
but if he's drinking he wants everybody
else around him drinking yeah so uh Jin
goes man had a great uh Saturday with
jelly roll and then sent me this video I
want you guys to see how blitzed chin is
in this video my friends are worried
about me getting off jelly rolls tour
bus hit it Jen there we go
so jelly leaves first
jelly people are screaming jelly roll
jelly roll
and where's this at at Honda Center
Anaheim the three performance yeah I was
freaking insane dude sold out pretty
much Jesus and they're speeching dude
they're like [ __ ] sit down dude
you're tripping who's telling you to sit
down Santi
oh you had your buddy with you yeah and
right there there's a do you recognize
George Lockhart oh yeah and then there's
also [ __ ] Corolla Jason perilla
hanging out with jelly holy schnikes
and is Lockhart helping jelly roll out
with the dying or no I think so so I
think hopefully knock on wood did they
just start or
and there's a concert by the way
[Music]
he's gonna sing Sweet Home Alabama yeah
he did a cover
it's freaking lit dude
[Music]
yeah dude yeah
our boy jelly roll is blowing blowing up
blowing up got it and he still it
doesn't matter he's still so sweet to us
oh he's such a good person well [ __ ]
thinking about when he came on firing
the kid Brian was in here is me jelly
roll and Jeff die if anybody he came
straight from The Tonight Show I know
insane dude
he's such alone on radio all the time
now here yo in California
yeah just such a good dude he's such a
sweetheart fuzzy feeling inside yeah so
you how'd it work you just uh drove to
wherever he's at and jumped on the tour
bus like a little lizard we saw the
concert and then his boy his tour
manager uh him jelly and me were talking
and then his tour manager helped me link
up with jelly after his performance
after his show until I went to the to
his bus to just chill yeah and I
literally honestly I remember getting to
the bus hugging and jelly and then
talking to George and Jason for a little
bit I have no idea what I said I have no
idea what we talked about really zero
clue you were you were [ __ ] destroyed
dude you're trash Panda that night yeah
well how did you get so hammered
because we were drinking throughout the
day I figured you were with gel and you
know how jelly forces people to drink
yeah I'm pretty sure I drank your own I
was kind of fine getting there to the
bus but when I left the bus I was gone
dude wobble Street and it looked like it
was Daylight out no it was still it was
dark oh it started at seven o'clock I'll
probably like drink at nine or eight
yeah children's white girl wasted
they're so wasted but it was amazing
chocolate wasted yeah it was awesome
dude you had fun yeah yeah Jelly's
crashed it moved yeah and then where's
he headed to now I think this was
supposed to be the end of the tour I
think I'm not sure I would have came
it's uh I almost said it sucks but I
would have came but my uh my pops was in
town oh yeah that'd been frowned upon oh
no he's still going he was a San Diego
Flagstaff Vegas
downtown rocks at the Fairmont Street
Experience wow and all these dates I'm
sure they're partying so hard I don't
know how he's gonna do he's doing Red
Rocks that's a bucket list Red Rocks
yeah yes
Bill Burr filmed especially his new
special there that place looks beautiful
Red Rocks is sick I'm surprised you
haven't seen a concert there too Dave
Matthews goes there like big boys one
day damn look at jelly roll doing the
damn thing glad you had fun dude so you
don't remember it
the stuff I do remember was awesome it's
a good time yeah she had some video of
it at least somebody took some video
Just You Hammer come out of the tour bus
Chin doing on there that made it be wild
just lot lizards on the bus and just
drinking getting wild he said he was
left here by the way what'd you say he's
sending you his love oh yeah yeah
absolutely love jelly we'll text each
other randomly here's the thing about
jelly though you'll attack some normal
hour of the day say 11 or noon I'll text
back at 6 p.m like just woke up man
what's up I'm like what my day's over
dude but he just you know he's a night
out let's stay up to four or five A.M
he's on that weird shift yep and you can
drink great guy though yeah Papa's in
town went to that uh was it Jack what
was it called Mark Jack Jack Jack night
of the Jack night of the Halloween thing
it's right up here chin you should go
you should definitely go if you have a
if you have like a girl oh you told Mark
to bring his girl and then I brought my
literally my whole family we posted a
picture of the kids absolutely loved it
man oh neither Jackson about the King
Ranch up here I've been there before
yeah
oh dude uh that's why I found that pizza
food truck Casey they have all these
food trucks there it was so much fun man
so much fun
and they have bar there so yep they have
bar there so you can get you know and
that the best whiskey that has was
bullet we should have tiger thick
sponsored or something hell yeah
yeah it was dope though that's what I
did pants came out for the weekend
pops went with me to this went to the
car show yesterday that's it man uh as
far as fight World goes we had a we did
a special uh food truck so last week we
did our fight night flashback with Frank
Mayer which was fantastic because
Frank's such a legend and then uh on
Saturday it was only day either one of
us could do it Saturday we had the one
of a kind Sean Strickland on Sean
doesn't do a ton of media and uh this
guy put press conference King there I
love this guy's comment
but I just give him shoes we know we
don't care about he'll see he does not
I'll just spoil it for you now so we we
had these uh Pata uh Air Maxes and
they're they're the murdered out Air Max
all black right like you're not gonna
give him zebras Yeezys or vault Yeezys
or you know some crazy mummy dunk or
some cool uh you know J Balvin Jordan
one not just you're not gonna do that
with this guy so the guys who uh uh
this lady but or this is a guy I can't
tell uh is the long hair I can't tell
though it's a small picture I'm trying
to clown he put which which episode of
Love on the spectrum is this
[ __ ] [ __ ] John
um no but uh so back to the shoes so the
the company uh suplex out in Philly soup
like Philly do this does the shoes when
I know the gas we're roughly about a
week or sometimes it's days before and
Sean was pretty you know decided to do a
pretty uh
swiftly so I had to get on it so I hit
up suplex I was like hey uh this guy
Sean Strickland's coming on and uh he
wears a size 12. he's like what the hell
do we do for Sean Strickland I was like
I'll be honest dude he was like boots
and whatever uh Ed Norton wears on
American history so I don't you know
sneaker wise he's not a sneaker head
yeah and then I was like I would
probably lean into the black like not a
lot of crazy colors and he's like we
have these Pata uh Air Maxes I'm like
God damn those are a nice shoe it's
probably a 600 shoe and I'm like yeah
send them it's the only size got in that
black so they send them and uh
you know
it went how you expect John was just
like oh man I appreciate it but I'm
never gonna wear these but his manager
Tim Simpson uh when we got off or maybe
set it on there I forget yeah those are
it right there when he got off he was
like uh his manager was like oh man I've
been looking for those I'ma Sneakerhead
and uh they work with Leon Edwards too
he's like Leon Edward's a huge sneak out
we gotta get him on like if he's a
sneaker head we'll talk about sneakers
the entire goddamn episode like there's
nothing more I love to talk about but
he's like yeah Sean doesn't wear
sneakers I've been looking for those men
he said I wish they're my size I was
like what size do you wear he's like 12
I'm like hey Sean I know you're probably
gonna go home and burn these do you mind
if I give them to your manager he's like
oh hell yeah that's a good idea I was
like thank you sir that's awesome but
John you know Sean Sean Sean's uh a one
of a kind he's uh you know he has his
his ideas and his thoughts and
you know it's on you know yeah you know
you know what you're gonna get I don't
think anybody's like what the hell that
guy said this I think you guys know what
you're gonna get that's Sean that's why
you'd have them on and you know he's the
answer one I'll leave it there is this
one and the other thing is is you know
he's coming off that Pierre loss but
he's in such a good position because
even though he's ranked number seven uh
Jared Canada I think is three or two if
he beats Jerry Canon or Canada might be
two or three so if he beats cat and air
he's back in the queue for a title shot
so life is good in the Sean Strickland
land you know
life is good
now I'm sure YouTube will demonetize you
know some of the things we talked about
but
you know it's not my I'm not you know
I'm not Twitter I'm not Instagram I'm
not YouTuber I'm gonna silence a guy for
his beliefs even if I don't believe in
it or if I don't agree freedom of speech
yeah so I'll entertain it you know and
me and him do have some debates we we
have some arguments on there it's a good
show and listen I like that I don't take
it personal like when someone has a
point I fire back them if I like I hate
when this girl that's our that's a good
point now man come on let's go let's do
it it's fun for me you know so you know
he's a he's a thinking man you know I'll
leave it at that he's a you know it's
Trump's trickling so you guys know what
you can get yeah and that drops on when
is it case Wednesday that drops on
Wednesday so enjoy that food truck
Wednesday with Sean Strickland we got
another big guest coming up as well so
you have the bow nickel one you have my
favorite one one of my favorites by far
Chris Barnett if you guys if you guys
are just new to food truck I'm doing it
I think five years now if you're new to
it
I've been doing this for a hot second
with these Fighters the Chris Barnett
one is my favorite one that guy's energy
he's so positive that's what I like
and then Sean Strickland the completed
opposite he's a guy who you know he has
a different set of beliefs but he stands
by him which I you know will respect and
and he's even down to debate it I'm all
for it
Norman argument I don't like should have
been a lawyer you know
I have too much CT to build and finite
flashbacks but Frank mayor that was
Fight Night flashbacks with Freddy yeah
he's great super dope yeah let's take a
little break kids me just chatting your
ear off about the MMA world because few
housekeeping notes so we can keep the
lights on keep giving you guys quality
products that's right speaking of
quality that sweet sweet tiger thick
nectar is back in stock it's not
pre-sale it's none of that it's straight
up in stock at my friends at bourbon
Outfitters you can go to thick boy.com
right now click on tiger thick and get
that sweet nectar right now delivered
straight to your door holler at your boy
award-winning taste tested all sorts of
awards it's going nuts all around the
water coolers people who can't get
enough this sweet nectar it's finally
back in stock and the new bottles have
the awards on the side it's gonna be lit
the batch too I'm so excited about it so
go to thickboy.com right now click on
tiger thick get that sweet nectar right
now we back in stock baby it's a digital
world I'm just a digital girl living
this digital world but listen when I'm
at a cafe sipping on an eight shot of
espresso whatever I'm doing I'm on my
laptop I'm on my cell phone I'm worried
are people hacking my stuff are people
stealing stuff that's why I reached out
to my friends at Avast it's the global
leader in cyber protection for more than
30 years is trusted by over 435 million
users prevents over 1.5
billion attacks every single month all
right a vast empowers you with digital
safety and privacy no matter where
you're at where you are who you are we
got you man enjoy the opportunities that
come with being connected on your terms
right a vast new all-in-one solution
Avast one helps you take control of your
safety and privacy online through a
range of features all right Avast one is
their best protection yet giving you
everything you need to take control of
your safety and privacy online all right
it's accessible through a single easy to
use interface it's super easy they also
include the free version right which
also includes essential features such as
the free antivirus free VPN free
firewall protection we got you covered
man then they have the premium version
which is more advanced protection so it
allows you to protect multiple devices
we got you covered man all right Avast
privacy features keeps your identity and
actions hidden so you don't have to
worry about that stuff anymore man all
right anti-virus award-wing antivirus
that stops viruses and malware from
harming your devices VPN
you don't want people to know where
you're doing all your stuff at man all
right you don't want to know and that's
why it's going to protect you all right
if you're a public Wi-Fi at the airport
you're at a cafe you had Starbucks be
protected man a vast got you covered man
and I want to thank Avast for supporting
the shop show confidently taking control
of your online world with Avast one
helps you stay safe from viruses all
right attacks ransomware hacking
attempts and all other cyber crimes we
got you covered man learn more from
avast1 at avast.com
avast.com
the shop show is also brought to you by
the best Kratom on the planet listen
Kratom is the wild west like CBD back in
the day you didn't know who to trust who
to use any show you watch whether it's
fight companions food truck Diaries
Fight Night flashback shop show find the
kid King this thing one thing I can
guarantee you is I'm on Happy Hippo
Kratom I swear by it I reached out to
them to be a sponsor the show because I
use the product I pay my own hard money
to buy their product not even more
because another sponsor thank God happy
hippo is the best Kratom on the planet I
use it for everything I do including
stand up on the road it's the one go-to
I have I take the pink lemonade shots
right before I hit the stage boom your
boys like Elon Musk out there so if you
want to try Kratom but you don't know
who to trust trust your thick friend
here because I trust happy hippo and you
can visit happyhippo herbals.com use
promo code sick boy you get 20 off for
freaking life use the code as many times
you want share with your friends your
aunts your uncles your stepdad stepmom
grandma grandpa whoever wants to use it
you can use this code as many times as
you want you go to happyhippo
herbals.com promo code thick boy with
three C's 20 off for Life best grade one
on earth happy hippo and we got Frank
coming on uh fight campaign so for the
was it 29th case for the 29th you have
Calvin kator and Arnold Allen and then
that night you also have
um
Jake Paul versus Anderson Silva and then
I'm sure you have in your current events
and you also have Uriah Hall versus
Lavon Bell it's so funny the team when I
was here on Saturday for the fight Camp
I'm sorry for the food truck sit down
and they're like dude you believe this
[ __ ] I'm like what I'm like dude Uriah
Hall versus Lavon Bell and I live on
right lady yeah Le'Veon Bell like you
believe that [ __ ] I was like
that's the co-main event like yeah I was
like take all my money stay tuned that's
the best fight on the card just from
like uh is there a bit of a circus shirt
but just from like the the interesting
like entertainment Factor do you guys
realize what Uriah Hall should do to
Le'Veon Bell like you know Le'Veon Bell
just won that fight he knocked out Jason
Peterson do you know how much better of
us it makes me laugh do you know how
much better [ __ ] Uriah Hollis is a
striker then Adrian Peterson and I know
Le'Veon Bell's probably feeling himself
like knock out Adrian Peterson dude I've
trained with your eye haul for years you
have no idea what you sign up for that's
why I can't wait for it
you know we talk about you know there's
you know UFC guys as far as athletically
your MMA Professionals in general
whatever champ you want any top 10 guy
you want athletically compared to the
NFL guys
it's a different set of skills but if
you can you know look at athletically
like the 40 time the the 5 10 5 uh Dash
the agility drills the cone drills the
three cone drills the 225 bench the
vertical jump all that the UFC uh
athletes that's not what they do that's
not their skill set so if you're
comparing that to them there's nobody in
the UC you can even close competing with
that as far as athletic wise and then
NBA and
um you know MLB different animal
especially NBA
but your eye Hall athletic like that's
the other thing if Le'Veon Bell oh he's
just a UFC fighter he's probably not
athletic Bubba listen I had a cappuccino
with the Buffalo Bills but I've been
around those high level guys Uriah Hall
is a freak athlete he's the one guy that
you [ __ ] up with because you think
he's gonna be like this stiff kind of
fighter Uriah Hall is a [ __ ] freak
athlete dude freak so it's like out of
all the this makes you laugh out of all
the guys to fight you got the one freak
and he's super technical I can't I'm
more excited for that than him Jake Paul
Anderson Silva when they told me they
thought it was gonna like shy me away
from doing the fight campaign I was like
oh my God we have to do it now this
makes it so much better yeah that's the
most interesting fight on the card not
because Le'Veon Bell is going to do well
but because you're gonna see the
difference you're gonna see the
difference and Le'Veon Bell you're
talking about complete freak I mean
[ __ ] freak of all freaks running back
like such a Savage I think you went to
Michigan State like Jeff freak one of
the best running backs in the NFL for
about two years
All Pro
okay
you [ __ ] you're messing with the guy
who is actually probably one of the most
athletic ride up there with a lot of the
NFL guys Uriah Hall and he has all the
technique now it's boxing
so you're not going to get any you know
spinning heel kicks like your house you
know talented at but just it's gonna be
trouble so he's uh what's it say so I'm
just excited to watch Hall versus bows
in for Paul versus Silva MVP promotion
co-founder and nakisa you have legit top
10 MMA Striker versus world-class
athlete has proven proven he has true
box skills and knockout power well the
fight elevates our pay-per-view to a new
level these guys will never put on for
unforgettable fighting fans I'd be
surprised
if Le'Veon Bell lasts more than two
rounds I'd be shocked I'm telling y'all
if you gave me a list of freaks that
I've trained with them and do you if you
watch this show people make fun of you
know shop sharing with all these guys
yeah I have dude I was around for a hot
second jumping from Camp to camp and
they come to my Camp when you have a big
Camp guys navigate there so I've trained
you name it I've probably trained with
them Uriah Hall is top three biggest
freaks I've ever seen inside that gym he
is a [ __ ] Savage it's hilarious to me
so we'll see I I can't believe belt
signed up for it
you know yeah
you also said that Uriah is like a
sometimes the pressure gets to him
you're right here so Uriah Uriah if you
took
if you took Beau Nichols
brain and put in Uriah you have the best
fire of all time
impossible to take down a little
impossible to [ __ ] take down me Mark
Munoz [ __ ] Patrick Cummings
um ishi unit Bisbee everybody try to
take this he's [ __ ] impossible
takedown when he doesn't want to get
taken down and then just his athletic
ability his hips are ridiculous his
hands are ridiculous his creativity's
insane inside the gym
you know I would say Cub Swanson's
probably the kip Swanson and Jon Jones
probably the best or Todd Duffy one of
those three probably the best ever seen
in the gym and then your eye hauls I
mean right wherever you want to put them
right one a one B one seat your right
hall is right there how's it going this
guy's never gonna [ __ ] lose Remember
The Ultimate Fighter
and what the UFC and it's not their
fault um I'm not you know knocking Dana
for the three he's like he he's an
extension Silva what they didn't know is
he wasn't mentally prepared for that
pressure they couldn't have done it to a
worse person he's a guy that should have
gradually brought up got his confidence
and then you're talking about with
all-time greats when you [ __ ] with
somebody's mental you know confident
stuff like that you fracture it think
about it think what he did to uh Gengar
Musashi
this arguments is the best metal weight
on the planet
does he beat is he I don't think so but
I'm up for the debate sure as [ __ ] is
one you'll get who Musashi's beat
you're right hall that's how good it is
on any given night spinning [ __ ]
he'll kick into the god dude
kid is a um because it's a Savage here
though
put Kobe Bryant's mind in we have the
the best MMA fighter of all time
I'm so excited for that fight I'm so
excited we're gonna have a good squad uh
I get started on that long tangent on
that uh fight comparing the 29th of
October I'll be flying back that morning
from Calgary so I'm gonna touch down
kiss my kiddos feed them change shower
and come right here
um
so
how long of a flight is it five hours
yeah or from that's from Toronto but
basically oh Trump but Toronto yeah
Toronto is complete opposite Chicago's
more in the middle
that's not about three hours three hours
not terrible you told me five was like
um
point is for that fight companion we're
gonna have a squad and all now it's one
of the members now we got Frank Mayer oh
yeah probably have Jesse from uh Jesse
on flyer if you know Jesse on fire the
hardcores went on him he's a big MMA
head one of the Brilliant Minds in the
game I mean him have been buddies for a
while we're gonna fly him out mix it up
and then we'll announce the rest of the
cast we've got a fun Squad man because
remember
you're doing two of them you're doing
UFC Fight Night and the Jake Paul
Anderson Silva so we gotta you gotta
navigate you gotta have the right team
who can withstand that kind of long
period [ __ ] watching we did it before
though we did before but we took a break
yeah that's true it takes a special guy
with Bert you know with Bert Kreischer
my favorite guest of all time on uh
fight campaign but uh Cowboys fight can
pay I'm not talking about the old school
ones Rogan Rogan's my favorite but um as
far as here combat's fight campaign Bert
crash is my favorite of all time when it
got done I was killing was that like an
hour everyone's like do you get over
three hours almost four I'm like what
but it's just my favorite person I just
[ __ ] love Bert Kreischer
it was so good so those would be fun
though those will be fun
and they'll have a special announcement
we have another companion uh coming up
in December as soon as that contract
once I sign the contract that thing
dries I'll announce it we don't announce
anything till it's official trust me
I've learned that Shin do you remember
when we were doing big big brown
breakdown and I had that deal with HBO
for the Canelo Triple G Fight their
first fight do you remember that I
couldn't remember that dope ass poster
with Canelo my boy I forget his name now
God he's such a good artist but he did
this dope poster and I was like the old
school ref
and it had Canelo on the top had
um Triple G at the bottom it said HBO
and I was gonna do
I was gonna do like a I was gonna do a
pre and post fight thing for them for
HBO's before I have Showtime clearly and
but then the night before I was gonna do
a show at the Hard Rock Casino and
Canelo was going to come with this whole
thing
and then somewhere
I forget HBO got mad at some some of the
marketing and then we're going back and
forth and then they tried uh kind of
editing my set like can you use a
rundown of your comedy set we're gonna
do and I was like I'm not sure what that
has to do with you guys like well HBO's
can be in this you know in the room and
blah blah and I was like okay it's a
comment it's stand-up show like I don't
skip so right now I'm running like oh
you need to get rid of this I'm out but
I announced it I posted I had the poster
freaking uh roots of fires making
t-shirts that's why they made the the we
did a big brown
um breakdown and Canelo t-shirt for that
fight remember that oh yeah yeah man
dude those were great shout to Jesse
roots to fight they're still crushing it
they just did their uh Ken Griffey merch
fire that big brown breakdown shirt that
they made was so dope I still have it
remember yeah hell yeah you weird I I
need to call Jesse see if they still
have some in the warehouse I think my
girl just gives away to Brandon Mexican
kids I like there's some random ex kid
who's looking fly as [ __ ] at school
right now or in college because he's
wearing my big round breakdown uh Ruto
fight shirt he's and he's wearing my
Travis Scott Air Maxes did you just give
him what you never wear these Mike are
you are you out of your mind
there it is there it is right there
that's so dope
see says Canelo or Cinco de Mayo and
then you turn around yeah yeah uh Los
meros meros de Mexico my girl had to
help me with that
God look how young we are there chin
look at that big brown breakdown episode
23 Mario Lopez yep I'll never forget it
I thought we had kicked out I told you
out there when you get kicked out why oh
being him started arguing over uh Connor
yeah because he because the fight was
even announced yet and I was like it's
happening yeah that's a stupid fight but
I'm like what's not stupid remember I
was kind of negotiating with Showtime at
the time too that's how I got my foot in
the door showtime and he was like it's
such a stupid fiber I'm like you you're
AC Slater though right so let's shut the
[ __ ] up you were telling me Conor's
gonna land shots he's gonna probably win
some rounds he's like no that's not
happening Connor won't land a single
punch and I was like oh God damn it
it got stressful for a little bit I
brought chicken
wow we're at his lot yeah well to be
fair when he sat down I was like oh
you're not gonna turn around say like AC
Slater I'd be just being silly he was
all
I was like okay and then also he had
full-blown makeup on yeah but wasn't
wasn't shooting that day
so he sat down he's like you know and
listen he's had a great career best
career out of all the state by the Bell
cast so anyone that parlays that and has
an amazing career like he has Kudos man
I have so much respect for Mario Lopez
and listen to be fair as far as
Hollywood goes Mario Lopez is a bat he's
a tough dude he's boxes that you know
he'll actually get in there and you know
he'll play fight with Canelo you know do
stuff but no he will Spar like he'll
actually Spar and do all that [ __ ] yeah
but he uh
for him to you know do that in spirit
but the other my point is he is so
ingrained because if you know in the
hotel he has to get paid Buco dogs for
this you know when I stay in hotels on
the road sometimes he's on every TV
you know he'll be like you know the the
new the whatever the new Purge seven
he's like hey everybody it's Mario Lopez
the new Purge seven brought to you but
you know it's true he's Frank Grillo
he's on all the things yeah he's on so
he does that but I think when you're
showing grain that Hollywood lifestyle
he can't turn off so remember it was
just me and Chin his assistant was like
here's Mario you know have fun guys left
us in the studio
his producers listen there but he was
like hey Brandon how you doing and no
one's and there's no cameras on anything
Brandy you having a good day hey let me
ask you something uh I gotta ask you
I've been thinking about this uh let me
ask you what's tougher I'm fighting
inside the Octagon or doing stand-up
comedy and I was like who the [ __ ] you
what what are you talking about why are
you talking like that why do you have
football makeup on what are we doing
right now and we sat down I was like
you're not gonna spin the chair around
say like AC Slater he's like
are you ready to start the interview I
was like no I went no oh no no no it's
not it's not your interview it's it's a
big round breakdown so I'll run it from
here I'll take it from here and you know
he loves boxing so it's heavy boxing
but yeah I like the guy I have no issues
with him no no I don't think he's
interested it's cool yeah he didn't kick
it out Jim was so weird when we got
Jones like holy [ __ ] dude that got
intense
but to me it's again it's never personal
like even with who I absolutely love and
adore uh um
um what's his [ __ ] face Ronaldo oh
yeah
um Mario Mario
adore him worked with him multiple times
remember
we did a uh thing in New York Showtime
filming him out we're on this rooftop
you weren't there reaching my brother
was there no but I remember the episode
we're on this rooftop
um I think I was doing promo for my
Showtime social but we're on this route
they rent out a [ __ ]
building in New York who's skyscraper on
top of the skyscraper and there's this
whole setup lights and everything and me
and him are straight up arguing over
um
Conor McGregor and Floyd Mayweather yeah
now remember his job as the boxing head
and boxing enthusiasts and boxing expert
not a boxing expert never claimed to but
his job was to defend box and Floyd
Mayweather
I was only hired to defend Conor
McGregor
so once you give me my assignment that's
the pay gig
no matter if I agree with Ronaldo or not
my that's not my job my job and I
honestly did believe it and it came to
fruition I was right Connor would win
some rounds and land some shot
that was the goal of that thing
but again mean it got heated me and went
back and forth heated but none of it's
ever personal that you know what I'm
saying like you like friends can argue
like that or mean Brian do it all the
[ __ ] time me and Roe can do it all
the time we'll have one opinion have
opinion we'll go back and forth no one
hangs up the phone gets mad there's two
dudes that have a different opinion and
then at the end you're like okay cool
man what else is up ah not much that's
it that's how it should go I mean well I
think uh tomorrow when he got dinner
after this we argued like a [ __ ]
it's so much fun I loved argue
it's a good time
yeah those are those are really exciting
times I remember we went to Vegas too we
did a podcast there with Luke Thomas in
a hotel that's right dude dude great
times those those Hotel uh podcasts yeah
that's right Luke Thomas did it ran long
yeah I remember that I actually I was
talking to Luke this weekend Oh dope and
stuck in Luke this weekend in jail
um you get chill out here we get chill
in a fight campaign oh that'd be amazing
I remember I did a podcast before Tim
Dillon was big I was in Dallas and he
was this is how Tim's a big boy Tim's
doing theaters if he does a club it
sells out in 30 seconds you know Tim's
I absolutely loved him Dylan right me
and Tim talk all the time I [ __ ]
loved him
he uh
this out fought longer it was five years
ago maybe six years ago I don't know
five years I don't know five years ago
maybe four years ago before you know now
before his Timmy Dillon he was doing uh
hyenas which in Dallas there's the
Addison Improv where I shot my special
which is the bigger Club there's hyenas
which is a good club but Tim does hyenas
because when Tim was coming up they were
the only uh venue that really gave him a
full weekend so that's how good of a
person Tim is he goes but he won't play
he'll play anywhere he probably played
Dallas [ __ ] Cowboy stadium if he
wanted to but he does hyenas because
they they gave him a full weekend before
he was Tim Dillon so Tim Dylan I'm at
Addison Improv it's probably four or
five years ago he's at hyenas and he's
like hey will you do my podcast I'll
come to your hotel
I was like sure dude I didn't know he
had a podcast
and his guy Ben was there set it all up
you know that's before Ben was Ben yeah
those those uh dude do you remember when
we were on the road in in uh England and
I we have to do a big round uh breakdown
from my hotel and we were in yeah on a
busy in London remember I was just on my
bed tired yeah it was like 11 at night
in the UK and I was just laying on the
bed like breaking [ __ ] down I remember
dude really we never missed episodes
ever ever I don't miss yeah dude I can't
it's a problem people say I work too
much in a hotel at 11 PM in London oh my
too much excuse my dad
touched down I and he uh took an Uber
because I was working took an Uber from
the airport with my stepmom and he walks
in a human big cow he says what's up to
the kids you know and then he said okay
what's up Dave's not how much he goes
working too much huh I was like what he
goes you look exhausted I'm fine here's
your final yeah he said all right
tonight we do this I go here's the thing
about tonight I have a set of Laugh
Factory he's like you piece of [ __ ] I
was like Dad I didn't know you didn't
give me a heads up I can't change my
schedule it's all right so Saturday this
thing about Saturday so I'm gonna go tie
your soccer game even come to that it's
gonna be a fun time right he's like yeah
I'm like and then I go do a food truck
so you can come with me he's like why
would I go with you at Fair Point
that was a good time
new merch just dropped as well kiddos we
got the they call it I don't know why my
boys called it
um
uh tie-dye yeah I would call it well I
call it tie-dye they call it the stealth
collection like I don't know what
stealth ninja would be in black and gray
tie-dye because you don't look very
ninja-like I think maybe because it's a
little camouflages but yeah maybe but
it's the I don't know why I didn't wear
it today because I'm a [ __ ] idea to
think about it but uh and it's even cold
outside thank God finally but they have
the tie-dye thick Boy Nation hoodie I'm
sorry not hoodie sweatshirt I don't
think we've done sweatshirt before so we
have the thick Boy Nation uh uh
sweatshirt we have the t-shirt and we
have the shorts I should wear the whole
[ __ ] get up today but I have CT and
totally forgot that we dropped it on
Friday and I was supposed to be
promoting the entire week before and I
did not
okay you guys can you guys go through
somebody else I just I totally forgot
totally forgot
totally forgot you have any here
uh we have the new merch that uh Marcus
rocking that drops in like three weeks
so go ahead and step into the camera
mark
some Mark is the low dunk or the low
[ __ ] Jordan dog son look at that
thick boy diet
so there's a knife for a cut and steak
there's a donut and that's whiskey nice
hoodies and tees
yes sir those comments death has giant
logo hilarious Precision candy SunRail
says hard and then uh this guy put God
is great you ain't lying dude God is
great
they look freaking dope though yeah and
I I tell the staff this all the time
whenever merch drops
any sizes you guys want just tell me
chip I know I would love for you to rock
that the or the I brought merch for the
entire team on Saturday the new thick
boy diet merch did you guys use it did I
see the bags empty
did people take it yeah it's that
I didn't know there's long sleeve and
that's long saver is that a hoodie
oh [ __ ] I know there's a long Thief damn
it
how do we know these days nice
oh dope
those were for Colin Casey that's cool
[Music]
you got yours tiled in that's what Kyle
gets we're working on the weekend not
with us
not with us
um but let's get into it Jen all right
Boston's grown up so fast dude
it breaks my heart
kind of crazy
nothing yeah he's so [ __ ] cute it's
so frustrating dude look at him in the
look at the Halloween ones
leave us see the Halloween pictures
where I'm at uh yeah that one
he looks okay he looks tiny there again
he is small in that picture you look big
but Tiger's [ __ ] big
oh my gosh dude it's so cute
yeah he's still really small he just
looks big in that pick yeah look at him
yeah and that thing was late so that was
like 8 39 he was tired
look at your teeth yep
it's a great time
yeah it's always fun for kids man
yeah we we go balls deep for Halloween I
love Halloween kids love it as well yeah
so I have an idea what I want the family
to wear because my girls want to do
family costumes right
so we have one
we have one out one set of costumes for
the kids that we're at school and like
trick-or-treating and then we have one
just for me which I I don't know I guess
I'll wear hair and then the family will
take a picture of it and then they'll
probably burn it for Rick and Morty
so I'm gonna be uh Rick Tigers Morty my
girls
um summer the sister and then bossy's
pickle Rick
bosty as pickle Rick is cute as [ __ ]
this Spider-Man outfit is lit too
I don't think I've ever seen episode oh
bro I know dude
I mean listen I'm a loyal South Park Fan
because they're Colorado boys right and
I went to University of Colorado alumni
and they have both uh they have they
have the creators of South Park and me
on the Flyers now promoting CU which
didn't treat me great and then they also
failed them on their last test at the
business lead business school which was
South Park which has gone on besides The
Simpsons be the most successful cartoon
of all time but Rick and Morty as far as
like
funny not even close wow it's fantastic
and it's so creative it's so [ __ ]
kitchen and I'm not even a big cartoon
guy now but that [ __ ] sakes it's so you
got to see it dude yeah if if you watch
the pickle Rick episode and you're not
like holy [ __ ] it's fantastic it's
I mean dude the family because the
family's so [ __ ] up the family is
going to therapy in order to get a
family therapy Rick turn himself into a
pickle to get out of it
and then his his daughter's like uh do
you do you turn yourself in a pickle
because you don't want to get a therapy
he's like no no I totally forgot but
then he has a a needle that is uh it's a
syringe hanging above them where you
just hit something it turns back into
human being and she's like oh well if
you forgot then you probably don't need
this he's like no no don't take that and
he's like God damn it and then they
leave go to therapy and he's just
sitting there he's just all he's going
okay and he's like trying to roll and
rock and he rolls and rolls into the sun
he's about to die and starts raining he
goes down the [ __ ] drain uh the storm
drain and he gets into like the sewage
and then there's rats there and then he
kills a rat he's he's the smartest
person in the universe and he said turns
himself with all the rat uh bones and
muscle he turns himself in this like
badass superhero it's it's insane dude
it's so crazy it's so creative and well
done it's by far the best by far the
best
let's take another little break y'all
because I'm I'm worried about some folks
out there man your brain's not firing in
all cylinders and you you're just like
man I've been in that flow State before
I've been in the zone I know how to get
there what I do do I meditate do I swim
do I get in the sauna or you could just
use Alpha Brain the number one nootropic
on the freaking planet by my friend that
on it have you heard of Alpha Brain of
course you have well now it's available
to you you can go to audit.com shop
schab you order from the site you save
10 off the best nootropics on the planet
from my friends that are on it or you
can go to your local Walmart and pick it
up but you don't want to go to Walmart
stay safe time get delivered to your
door listen Alpha Brain you're talking
about science you're talking about
straight up case studies where it fires
up your brain all right it gets you into
that flow State promotes cognitive
function including your memory mental
speed and focus can help you remember
names who remembers so many names never
right all right it helps you zero in on
the the freaking job that you have at
hand to really focus and knock it out
the part Arc all right that's why Joe
Rogan swears by he says help him form
better sentences when he's talking do
you want to talk like Joe Rogan we all
do he's on Alpha Brain the Secret's out
he's using Alpha Brain if you're jittery
you're worried about caffeine it's
caffeine free baby that's right Alpha
Brain is caffeine free on it so
confident you're gonna love Alpha Brain
to give you your money back guaranteed
just give them two weeks and if at that
point you don't love Alpha Brain it's
not your fit all right all good just
tell them why they'll refund your money
on the spot no return necessary keep the
bottle that's your issue you can save 10
off by going to audit.com shop Schaub
all right and save 10 off the entire
website honor.com especially Alpha Brain
or you can go to Walmart get you some
man San Jose see you this Thursday
Friday Saturday San Jose Improv right
after that next week I'm in Salt Lake
City Utah Wise Guys October 20-22nd then
I end October in Calgary Calgary Canada
we have a show on the 27th of the
rooftop downtown Calgary that shows damn
near sold out so we add a show on Friday
to the rooftop on the 28th get your
tickets right now thickboy.com see you
there
yeah man so what do we got you all right
uh the first one is Alistair Overeem and
barahari they fought this is the third
fight they went they had in Glory
Kickboxing and those boys in their Prime
oh I see the Frank merely got it from
The Fight Night flashback yeah dude
before we see chance champ once
retirement fight on one pretty cool
condition I'll ruin it for you guys
fighting with his daughter that's so
cool that's the same card as his
daughter and listen Frank's good buddy
of mine we talk all the time but
I was not aware we don't talk about kids
how about fighting I wasn't aware of how
much of a badass his daughter is she's
insane University of Iowa ever heard of
it for wrestling on a scholarship not
those dude
so and then she's you know she's I think
3-0 in uh MMA and then she was a state
champ in Vegas at a big ass school and
then uh Frank's plan is to have little
Bella fight on the same card heifer is
the main event then how's it going
you'll be co-main event he's like no
because then I can't Corner her yeah so
you just put me on the card and so I can
Corner her he's like so I could be the I
could kick off whatever the fight the
main card then she's the main event
that'd be so sick and then his dad it
was his coach her Grandpa is also her
coach so her coach is his [ __ ] dad
who got Frank mayor to be a world
champion and Austria data is Frank Mayer
nutsos yeah and then his son
as a freshman played varsity at that big
ass school that's on ESPN all the time
in Vegas he's a linebacker he's a
[ __ ] freak those kids are freaks man
Frank there's a chatty Kathy like me
that's why when we were talking I'm like
let's do a fight companion dude you and
me on fight man we are Chad Kathy's then
he makes in matrone or somebody maybe
Sam Tripoli that guy Jesse too he's a
Chatty Cathy yeah do you see a chat yep
so you got four chatty Kathy's
this episode of fight commands brought
to you by Adderall
all right what do you got by the way
Frank's awesome too so he knows we
talked about the you know pinched nerve
stuff he has the same thing he had an
issue with his neck he had to have
surgery he connected me with this dude
he's like yeah just go check him out oh
sick yeah he's great
all right so I'll show over him I'll
show you this right so apparently um I
didn't watch this fight but barahara was
apparently winning doing really well and
then the and the final round uh Uber him
how many rounds did they go I think it's
three is it three yeah I didn't watch
the fight to be honest okay yeah so
round three
end of the fight uh Uber ream drops them
two times oh wow yeah
that'll do it yeah so I'll just play
this clip of uh an uppercut
from overing
we gotta get over him on uh
on uh food truck and Flash Fight Night
flashback
boom
now babahari is also six seven six six
huge dude
and just boom right on the chin dude
bought a heart in his [ __ ] Prime with
these SK him his brother Morocco the
scariest [ __ ] on the planet
like gangster scared oh yeah they don't
care dude dude Street Fighter Savages
yeah I have an end over him too I don't
know I didn't think about it
yeah someone someone remind me yeah my
uh one of my best friends Cody Diamond
was his coach in Colorado high altitude
oh [ __ ] he still trains there
hell yeah dude that'd be right everyone
they're saying over him too in the train
room's like the best training partner
now it used to be they're known for
breaking his toys not anymore he's like
the just spit knowledge on the
youngsters and him and curse blades
train together all the time Savage yeah
and I heard for the bottom hard fight
too like I guess botter's not doing that
great as far as you know maybe even
maybe even in his personal life but also
fighting he's not at his best but so
that's why over him's like I didn't want
to fight him in the beginning but then I
heard he called me out interesting so
otherwise I wouldn't have done it
because I don't want to hit someone when
they're down good for him yeah
what's this this is uh Greg Hardy so
he's fine I already got into boxing yeah
and I also I don't think that we're not
gonna hear from Greg Hardy and like ever
again I think Greg Hardy gets a few wins
and comes back to UFC so shouldn't have
everybody I think it's possible Daniel
loves him so yeah yeah
again Greg hard is the guy here at ATT
like dude super humble only her
respectful like you know he comes with
that baggage from his past but that's in
the past really good student just wants
to learn I have no issues with him and I
told you I looked at all that stuff like
I read about it and I looked at all the
pictures and stuff it's kind of I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know either whatever but I believe in
second chances yes yeah
all right so I'll just show you there's
no audio to this either but uh I'll just
show you real quick this is him
basically destroying this is a
professional boxing match yeah yeah you
can't do his very first one okay
half of the guy or half his size the guy
is visibly smaller than like a lot
smaller but this is heavyweight
God Chris Hardy is a Savage
oh yeah good slip there
and that was it that was it yeah here's
the thing though you know people oh
knocked out got half his size you ain't
chip Greg Hardy's never boxed
professionally before yeah this is how
boxing goes yep go watch Deontay
Wilder's first fight like this is how it
goes the unboxing that you're gonna you
know it's a it's a marathon it's not a
Sprint like UFC it's not like these
other leagues you're gonna start with
some shitty guys
that's exactly you know granted I wish
they was a little bigger but that's why
skill wise that's exactly who you should
be fighting right now
and then the next ones get tougher the
next one gets tougher next one gets
tougher and then he's gonna get South
Paul and the next one gets tougher and
then who knows yeah
but he's like a freak athlete so yeah
All Pro
uh this is also we all remember Julian
Lane the let me bang bro guy oh classic
Ultimate Fighter history let me bang bro
as he's crying bro
so kickbox the term bare knuckle boxer
Vlad destroys Julian Lane Instagram left
hook stopped him dead in this track yeah
dude this guy it's so accurate watches
punching the kickboxer guy
oh he's so good
oh my God
well that yeah that Russian guy is a
[ __ ] Savage fast actor yeah but also
Julian Lane don't look bad either like
him listen it's not a knock on Greg
Hardy but watching Greg Hardy's fight
Greg hardly kid it's tough tell where
he's at because that guy was so bad he's
fighting but that slip was dope slipped
to the right hand but then this Julian
lane and then that Russian cat that
Russian cat can [ __ ] fight yeah
yeah
yeah you hit someone he checked left
hook there and then as Julian Lane comes
in for those that can't watch it he
[ __ ] times it
so fast out out yeah perfect punch yeah
filthy
well okay I thought you couldn't fly
into Russia right now
I don't know what's going on there so
that brings me brings up this one here
too so it's called a segwidget yeah
perfect so there was rumors that hamzat
shamaya had his passport seized in
Russia and he couldn't leave but his me
uh his manager according to Brett
okamoto says that that was all yes I
just spoke to hamzat's manager who told
me reports of homs.b being stuck in
Russia with a revoked password not true
Hamza is in Russia but there are no
problems with any travel restrictions
Corner shamas shamus's Mandarin uh yeah
I don't listen Russia uh views Fighters
like America reviews NFL NBA players
they're not gonna forsake it or do
anything you know he's he's getting the
red carpet rolled out when he comes he
knows all the leaders yeah he's friends
with the leaders he's friends there but
they're not gonna stop him yeah
yeah but it was it was like a trending
topic for a little while dude can you I
was thinking about this I couldn't sleep
that I was thinking about this when I
first uh heard about this and we didn't
know I was like man can you imagine if
they make comms that pick up a [ __ ]
fight AKA 40 47 and fight and he dies
for what dude
how awful would that be
you want to go [ __ ] take Ukrainian
land and he dies doing that [ __ ]
yeah
dude yeah so I saw that stuff that keeps
me up that's how weird I am it's [ __ ]
up yeah so I saw articles about Russian
people leaving because they don't want
to shoot anyone they don't want to kill
anyone a lot of men are trying yeah yeah
and then the people who are protesting
it are just you know they're they're
getting arrested and then you're in a
rush and prison camp
it's all [ __ ] up if you want to know
what Russia prison camp is like go ahead
and watch the new season of stranger
things
yeah they're fighting those monsters
that's real that is a documentary it's
real okay
all right there's no fake news here all
real facts
I want to segue into that too but I
gotta find the article let's see
well I'll just talk about it first so uh
our board Legion yang he posted a
picture of him in a like a badass
tailored suit let me see I'm trying to
find out so he's been stepping up his uh
suit game huh yeah
I'm just gonna Google real quick so yeah
so he's there it is suit UFC 279 yep
no no no it was after that it was a
fight night
um
it's for the uh here it is the the
Facebook
no damn it it's not anyways I'll I'll
find it here but so Legion Ling posted a
picture of his him with a badass suit
just go to his Instagram oh yeah
she was like ah [ __ ] you're right yeah
yeah you are right
hopefully it sounds it has to be honest
Instagram there he is right there
and that's it so uh the leech butt
tailored this suit for yawn's fight then
heard the arena was rented out yeah
so you gotta fly ass suit on he looks
[ __ ] dope too it's not a conspiracy
dude it's real no I told you it's listen
it's it's not conspiracy there's no
debate about this he rented the arena
yeah you guys know how I feel about it
I'm pretty hard on the paint last
episode you know I just
you know that's why when people like oh
whatever shops full of [ __ ] is
conspiracy needs to Handler UFC 279 how
could it be fake
and I'm not dying on that hill and the
odds are you guys are right there's no
conspiracy I'm just saying it just lined
up a little too perfect like JFK
shooting for me
that's all I'm saying yeah so when I
question everyone's like this is the
most ridiculous conspiracial it's not
that ridiculous
you know and then Dan's like it he's a
dumbass if you think that anybody you
know Pat milkshake think that but you
know well you've lied to us countless
times
guys have uh you know
that Miss Wade are usually
discipline like you want to believe
astral land just got cut because of it
you know there's a there's a smoke
there's a bit of fire again I don't even
know if you prove to me it's not true
okay I also don't really give a [ __ ] it
actually worked out better for Nate Diaz
that's all I really wanted yeah so cool
great grand wonderful and this you know
Mackenzie Jordan comes out and here's my
thing because he's doing not a liar and
when she does a press conference and
clearly nobody was a cameo don't mention
that Mark Zuckerberg went to the rain
out nobody told her that so when she
goes yeah main event but Mark Zuckerberg
rent at the arena Daniels that's
[ __ ] that's all smoking that's all
[ __ ] smoking mirrors that's not real
and we're watching like oh oh [ __ ] he
actually rented out and then leech again
nobody told him hey make sure you don't
draw the attention to Zuckerberg rent to
the arena hey rent this suit I can't get
in the arena well he's not media
remember Dana was like well no he didn't
rent it out we're just not letting
certain media in there
oh okay well leeches at media why can't
he come in
to support his girl because somebody
rented it out
yeah I just I don't know why he was so
adamant about saying it's [ __ ] it's
like just yeah I know it's just who
cares why would you lie just [ __ ] be
like yeah he I don't know dude was one
to himself he's big fan it's only a
fight night it's Apex Center so it's all
good
I don't get it I don't get it
all right so what do you think of this
fight Stephen Thompson versus Kevin
Holland after Kevin Holland recently
said he was retired
now he's back yeah Kevin Holland has a
new podcast too he just launched a new
podcast go let's do it download it it's
it he has two co-hosts on there it's a
it's a good show it's entertaining I'll
see Kevin Hans entertaining uh he went
on there and
he kind of called me out but it's uh he
also told you he also did it in a more
of a joking matter which I appreciate
um you know he's like Brandon is you
know it's great and I think it's because
my the UFC 209 conspiracy saying it's
not you know wasn't real which nothing
just got out of hand which if you go
back and listen to the show I'm like I
do think that it was real but if it was
to be a conspiracy this is the questions
I have if you remember go back and watch
that but our couch the media picks it up
and like oh Brandon this this this this
so of course Kevin Holland he's not
watching the show and he gets into it
right and he's like yeah for all the
crazy [ __ ] shop says I'd love to have
him on the show or um he wants me on the
show and he thought you know he was
talking to me on social media and he
wasn't stalking the staff so he's like
that was kind of embarrassing I didn't
know what to fire back I sent him a
video just be like dude I get it
um I was sensitive too when I was a
fight I'm sensitive now as a comic so I
completely get where you're coming from
and then he was like we need to box
though if you can comes on here I go on
his we need a box for all the [ __ ] he
says I told him I said I mean he goes
well I ain't wrestling his big ass
because I'm done with wrestling I retire
for a reason I just sent him a video I
was like you know basically good luck
with everything if you need help the one
thing I do know is podcasting if I can
help you in any facet and I've seen the
show it looks fantastic I don't think
you need any help but if you ever do I'm
here I was like are you at your mom I
would never block you why the [ __ ] would
I box you dude I'll see I need all the
brain cells I can mustard should do what
I'm trying to pull off I'm never gonna
box you I said but I'm down to come on
your show you can come online you can
hash it out if you want and uh and I
said also people get upset when guys
retire I said when you're not your
retirement I get excited because again
we're all a lot the fighters in UFC it's
like you know I made the joke about it
on the bit we posted in Ontario when I
was going through the day no drama
[ __ ] but it's like these Fighters
you know Kevin Holland for a guy like
him to get to the level he's at he's a
success story you're Andy defrainment
you crawl through [ __ ] dude and you make
it out the other side and now Kevin
Holland you know if he was retired I
told him I said you know you're in
Mexico you're insane watanio where the
[ __ ] it is so it's like good for you man
you you beat the game most guys don't
most guys stick around via BJ pan via
Diego Sanchez via the list goes on and
on but for him to be however 31 and he's
like I'm good made money I'm out ranked
in the top ten fought big fights I'm out
I was like to me like nothing makes me
more excited when guys retire and they
still have other [ __ ] to do and you
launch your podcast good luck dude you
know I said love to come on the show you
can come on mine I say here's the other
thing dude there's no pressure to do
either both of us will be fine if we
don't do each other's shows that's the
other thing no pressure dude see I like
Kevin Holland glad he's fighting again
I like watching it with Kevin Hans one
of my favorites that's autonomous Kevin
Hollins one of my favorite fighters to
watch he's great for the sport great
mouth be super [ __ ] entertaining
um you know fight against Wonder Boys a
great fight tough fight for both of them
can't fork in the road for both of them
and I also think Kevin Hong got the
[ __ ] shaft
so let's say there's no conspiracy right
and here Kevin Holland you're getting
ready to fight he's scheduled to fight
uh
was it Rodriguez no no he already fought
yeah Rodriguez a guy who's gonna just
stand up with him not gonna wrestle not
gonna grapple you've done your whole
camp for that and then the UFC goes hold
up the day before the fight hold up
we're gonna give you a guy who all he
does is wrestle not only does all he
does is wrestle but there's argument
probably the best Grappler we have right
now on a day's notice
okay now I'm sure you got compensated
more for that it's a catch weight but
still
not ideal man you know so he got the
even though I'm sure you got campsite
hit the short end of the stick man I
don't like that
so for him you know to fight Wonderboy
again a guy who's not gonna take him
down you're gonna get a great fight
and that's the five round fight too
so they're but for both gentlemen
they're they're this is a you know
forking Road fight because for Kevin
Holland
if you would have gave him a full camera
for Hamza you're talking about a
different fight attending Holland's a
black belt jiu jitsu
is his wrestling world-class nose
hamzatz yes but still you would I
guarantee he wouldn't have got finished
like that not a chance but stay up day
before yeah it's kind of crazy
effective so you gotta root for that guy
you know
so shout out to Kevin Holland good luck
with your new podcast my man I'll be
tuning in he's an interesting guy this
co-hosts are great it's a guy and a girl
and him sets dope well done audio's good
you know nice
all right she got you another fight
announcement Johnny Walker versus Paul
Craig hell yeah
and that's on the pay-per-view in Brazil
283 Brazil now
that's in Brazil right huh
let me care if I say this
but
a super reliable source told me that the
UFC is trying to get Jon Jones Stipe in
December
that's the big fight they're waiting for
huh and part of what works with this
because this person that it came from
that you guys would all know I'm not
gonna say her name I don't put them out
there like that
but part of the problem is is Gary's
ready to go too
yeah he was fight in December
and the UFC's going hold on we're
waiting to see if Jon Jones if Jon Jones
doesn't do it you'll come on he's like
well hold up I'm Eerie I'm the light
heavyweight champion of the world I wait
for nobody and you see this cool story
sounds good we're gonna wait for Jon
Jones if Jon Jones for whatever reason
can't do it we're gonna we're then
you'll fight he's like no no I'm the
champ
they're like no we're waiting for John
that's the that's the big fight in
December so they're waiting for John
Stipe
but the fight that they want most of all
is this so John Stipe is their second
choice
their first choice is John Francis and
they're hoping Francis re-signs and is
able to go to fight in like January
February
that's what they're hoping for they're
they they they would rather John go
straight to Francis than John go through
Stipe they want John Francis that's the
number one fight UFC wants to make
the caveat there is Francis the contract
the re-signing and then also his injury
yeah
but so they're so the UFC again they
they got the job cut out for them
because they're trying to figure get
deal with Francis see if they can come
to fruition if they can resign Francis
come to agreement then you have John
fight in probably January February March
at the latest against Francis if Francis
can't get that deal done or there's a
hold up or who knows then they're trying
to get John Stipe on the December 10th
card
hmm if they can't get any of that done
you're getting Gary Glover in December
interesting
and this isn't like rumors like you see
279 conspiracy these are fast
because that's what we do here at the
shop show okay
no check no fact checking
is allowed here
okay
all right so yeah that's a great push-up
and also this little nugget for you guys
huh
pretty big nuggets jacking off in the
corner
um so as you know Shot Rock one off he's
killing her it's a great fight yeah so
he's fighting this
fight dude Jeff Neal Jeff Neal hell yeah
it's uh January 14th
uh they're already announced in January
yep here we go Apex likely to be Apex
but that's a great fight yeah is that is
like the main event five rounds or no I
mean this has to be this guy has to be
main event
Maybe
especially if it's a fight night
um
oh that was another thing there's a back
and forth between them too
so shafka said I don't blame you for
doubting yourself but we're interested
to accept the offer such a good fight
the odds on that make me close yeah
minus 105 plus 100 I bet great fight
shall see that's a great fight yeah you
know we root for our boy Japanese Road
House Legend
yeah but toughest man to ever work at
Texas Roadhouse
Jeff new
I don't know what oh this we already
kind of covered this already though oh
yeah I covered this yeah so let's move
on this was the Le'Veon Bell URI hauling
so okay
um
Aspen lad she was just cut from the UFC
she's now joined the pfl we're not
making weight like three times in the
UFC and four times in our career yeah
yeah that's a problem but so now she's
moving up to featherweight and she wants
to get a fight with Kayla Harrison like
according to her manager they want that
fight and then Kayla Harrison posted
this as well
quoting uh your boy from Texas Matthew
McConaughey all right all right all
right yeah that'd be Kayla Harrison's
toughest fight yeah for sure right yeah
she's just mopping the floor with these
girls constant rematches with people
she'd be I know they're like rematch too
it's like that last fight was 40 seconds
the fight we've all been waiting for I
know can she last one minute without
getting absolutely destroyed
next pfl pay-per-view Kyle Harrison
murdering some young girl
Aston ladverse kill Harrison tougher
fight for Taylor Harrison Taylor
Harrison could probably be 99.99 UFC
roster so tough fight rasping lad but
also the toughest matchup for kill
Harrison so far which that isn't saying
much yeah
all right another fight announcement at
uh Frank Yeager his retirement fight is
going to be with the gentleman named
Chris Gutierrez I don't know much
Gutierrez no punk no he's not a punk
this is Frankie Edgar's record he lost
What four out of his last five four out
of five one two out of six that's tough
dude losing to really you know obviously
awesome to the spare guys he's about all
tip of the spear but this is Chris
Gutierrez he's kind of killing it uh
he's won one two three four five six in
a row
six one six hours last seven is only uh
non-win was a draw yeah he's a [ __ ]
beast yeah he's killing it last fight
come up performance of the night yeah
this is a good feeling though it's for
for Frankie Edgar New York Mets Square
Gardens I should send that guy oh yeah
and you got to do a sit down with him
he's he's amazing right he was basically
at the time it wasn't called food truck
at the time I forget what they called it
but it was uh I was in New Jersey for
show time and I went and got pizza with
Frank Yeager on Jersey Shore
he was the first guest ever oh yeah
uh another fight
Brian barbarino versus Rafael dos anjos
Fight Night Orlando love this fight yeah
shout out to Brian barbarina Savage
he's I mean obviously he's coming off
that huge win if you knock out Robbie
Lawler there's only one way to go and
it's you're going Sizzler you're
fighting monsters so you know dos anchos
is a monster yep
I highly doubt dos Santa is going to
trade with him though
yeah we'll see what happens there
um
there's a quick look at dosanjos record
so he just lost to Rafael faziv but won
the last two Ronaldo McConnell and Paul
Felder Paul Felder was short notice
super short notice I can't believe he
made weights yeah he's a badass
and there's
um Brian barbarino's record dude so this
would be Brian barbarino's last three
fights ready for this he beat Matt Brown
The Immortal ever heard of him beat
Robbie Lawler Legend ever heard of him
and lazy gonna fight dos anjos yeah you
beat Matt Brown Robbie Lawler and dosage
first of all the matchmakers love Brian
Barina that's what I that's in
conclusion to wrap this
summary up this Ted Talk of Brian
barbarina the the matchmakers love him
Matt Brown you're getting big time names
dude yeah
good for him
good for him indeed and also he has a
few final nights what's this uh so this
is Stephen A Smith and Jake Paul on Jake
Paul's podcast well Steven Smith came on
there yeah he didn't go on uh ESPN I
thought Jake was I thought Jake also
went on ESPN or this just on Jake Paul
this is just one where this is literally
just Jake Paul's podcast oh I didn't see
it went through it back back and forth
here let's see if it catches it good on
uh so it was about basically um Dana
White they're you know talking about
Dana White Stephen A Smith likes Dana
White and he's saying to Jake Paul like
because Jake Jake's saying like they
they're not paying Fighters enough this
and that but Stephen A Smith basically
said like you don't understand the inner
workings of the overall yeah which is
which is why I don't argue for it too
much I don't know their business I don't
know their overhead and he says I know
NBA or NFL or something like other
sports Ace Smith said that he goes I
know all those Sports we know the inner
workings of that yeah so yes but so it's
a it's a different thing because he was
saying like how come they're not getting
paid 10 million to this and I should
text Jake oh she he was doing this
caveat is when they do defend data and
say that and like we don't know the
inner workings cool we know the inner
work into the MLB we know that it works
at the NBA NFL why don't we know the
inner works in the UFC they hold
everything so tight to the chest they we
don't get UFC numbers anymore you know
we have to kind of find out certain
journalists have to do deep Dives on how
much they're getting paid from ESPN we
have no idea how they're doing on ESPN
right yeah so they hold it tight to the
chest my question would be for CMA Smith
why do you think UFC if you want to
Consumer top five sport in the world why
are the only major organization that
holds it so tight to the chest yeah
I would argue because they could pay the
guys more and they don't want that news
getting out because he gives the
fighters more ammunition to stand up and
demand more money that's why they're
doing it otherwise
let us know yeah why doesn't so touch
your chest why do you limit the what
press comes in
NFL didn't do that and they didn't do
that NHL doesn't do that MLB don't do
that
UFC does that White House does that
softball questions so early this week
Paul is on offensive again as he came
together uh with Smith on his BS with
GPS with Jake Paul YouTube show Once the
top return to UFC fireplace things got a
little heated Paul began to spit out
facts about uc's uh crazy Revenue share
and how white handles it all while Smith
he works with UFC broadcaster I mean he
kind of works oh he works yes he works
for his fan it is best to avoid say
anything professionally incriminating
that's my man I'm not gonna front uh uh
Stephen A Smith said Dana White's my guy
of course you guys are working together
yeah uh even if you don't like Paul or
hiking like stuff side of the Ring it's
a solid watch wow they need to give a
summary
I mean it was just super long but
basically you know just pretty much
Steven Smith was kind of Defending he's
another number one argument is we don't
know what it takes to run the game yeah
that's fair fair then show us if that if
that's the the
that's your argument saying we don't
know what it takes okay but you're right
then show us and if you show us in the
public can go through the numbers go
they actually don't have a lot of room
to pay guys more that ends the
conversation but have you ever ever seen
the UFC be open and talk about how much
money they're receiving how much it
costs to run everything never
only one can conclude and I don't have
any evidence but only one can conclude
the reason they're doing that is because
they can afford to pay guys more but
they don't want to and again I don't
know if I'd run the business any
different
yeah it's you don't know it's also
you're picking and choosing when you be
mad at you know uh Fair pay because
everybody watches a show the majority
unless you're watching this in Asia
everybody in here we all use iPhones you
know it's the worker that Apple get paid
nothing
the slave labor in China nothing
they make it work so long they commit
suicide they have a net to catch
employees from jumping off but you use
your iPhone now that would be an
argument for the UFC right
what else you got this is kind of like
piggybacking on this so Shane Burgos as
you know he left the UFC for pfl and
Dana White did kind of say he regretted
it because Burgos is such a game fighter
he's always fun to watch He's
entertaining he doesn't have boring
fights danger said they just he flew
under the radar yeah he's too busy
forgot about him he's saying that the
pfl is paying a stupid amount of money
and that when they had that contract uh
the negotiations to like you know match
his thing to leave or stay with UFC he
said the UFC would never match it
because if they matched his contract
other Fighters would know then they have
to pay other Fighters more so it's like
that's not true that's not true yeah I
get his point like if they do if the UFC
matches the north flash break wait a
second that happens all the time I mean
the amount of money that Izzy makes even
though it's undisclosed the amount of
money he's bringing in uh the amount of
money khabib was making you know his
manager Ali came I was like he's the
highest paid player of all time the
amount of money they're paying some of
these guys would blow your mind but I
think since Shane isn't like one of
those Fighters like the really you know
famous ones he was kind of like just a
fun fighter that would win yeah yeah so
he said I'm gonna make uh I'm gonna be
making a stupid amount of money again
it's all relative right I I'm curious
what stupid means to him so the money
was too good for me to pass up against
say no that money I've got kids I've got
to feed this it's the first time I did
the free agent thing the human offered
it was a great offer the first time in
my head I was thinking I'm a UFC fighter
at the time I was in a prize fire this
is time coming around this time come
around a little bit older now I'm 31 I'm
like I'm a prize fighter that's a prize
when I'm getting paid now that's a prize
that then on top of that you've got a
million dollar tournament and on top of
that you've got me doing a commentating
gig which is send me up for when I'm
done Computing sport it was no brainer
when he laid that out uh facts in the
pros and cons chart I agree with them
but also
um he's right because the Chan you know
how hard is becoming a analyst in the
UFC the thing about the guys who come
Alice so
Paul Felder is the only one who's
knocking me on the Mount Rushmore
and the reason Paul Felder is is it has
an ALICE gig she's so [ __ ] smart so
good he's he's an outlet yeah that guy's
a [ __ ] Jeff Bezos of comet commenting
he's a [ __ ] monster so he's an
outlier Paul Felder show good if you
want to you do NFL NBA MLB he's an
outline he's probably the best they have
who's not a former Champion then he got
Donna Cruz are you one of the best of
all time if not the best of all time you
got Michael Bisping Champion but you're
up on the map for MMA yeah uh Daniel
Cormier
uh light heavyweight champion
heavyweight champion Strikeforce
Champion uh Olympian one of the best
ever do it you know so first battle Hall
of Famer and he has a gold jacket who
else she got on that staff
that's about it
so you got Biz being
you got Paul Felder Dominic Cruz Cormier
Cormier
four guys
it's like being a part of our football
team
or say be a trumpet player trying to get
that Chicago Symphony you gotta hope
somebody dies you know what I'm saying
they're there forever so for him they're
going hey we give you a commenting gig
because listen I love Shane Burgos you
think he's taking Paul felder's King you
think he's taking bispings Donald Cruz
and Donald Cruz and I mean Bisping does
uh Dana White uh Contender shares and I
do some papers when Rogan's out but for
the most part it's tough man because all
the major pay-per-views you got DC and
Nick Rogan so the rest of the fight
nights which is a good amount they're
using you know Paul Felder Biz being uh
Brennan Fitzgerald
and then you also got Laura senko too in
the mix yeah it was a Savage hopefully
she gets to the actual commentary like
real commentary pay-per-view Booth
little birdie told me she this chance
that's gonna happen hopefully yeah
so for Burgos this makes all the sense
even though it's not the UFC and you
wish it was the UFC usc'd pay you what
you're worth and UFC would give you a
commentating gig the chance of that
happened and if I'm 31 I have kids like
him yeah this makes all sense to work
for him
yeah so good for him good for him yeah
killing it
I wonder how much he was making at the
UFC though
he's getting stupid money now
so
UFC person
let's see if it shows anything
oh Burger's made 156 in total when
losing losing against Barboza he's
making made a base salary of 75 they
took oh he made 156 because he made the
the the bonuses they gave 75 grand um
chamber wrote so his first fight is
making 10 and 10. oh man and then the
Reebok money 2500.
but so his last fight made 156 so he
would have made 150. so
his contract was 75.75
and then if you go up to how much does
it when it popped in the Google Search
Chamber goes uh
pfl contract
so if he's making 150 says stupid money
I don't think they're going to show
stupid would be
yeah it's the same article it's always
just making a stupid amount of money but
also yeah the chance to win the one
million dollar tournament
on top of your actual salary
so I would I would bet they're paying
500 000. can you imagine
yeah I can yeah damn that'd be
that'd be awesome
good for him yeah
okay going back to Jake Paul I'm sure
you've seen this video already with
Draymond Green punching his I guess his
teammate solid shot right like a good
super solid punch wobbles them if and
maybe have knocked him out here it is
right here yeah so I'll just play it
here
I'll use some background on this why he
did this too
so then we're talking about practice
we're talking about practice uh-huh
so he's talking [ __ ] Draymond Green
though I don't know if you guys know
about Draymond Green but he's he's
should be playing for the Detroit
Pistons back in the bad bad boy days
he's a tough guy he's the enforcer of
the team so he's walking up to right now
he pushes over boom that was a clean
screen and Draymond Green is a fan of
UFC and boxing so I met Draymond Green
at the Floyd Connor fight thin dude but
big big fight fan
um and he's kind of that's how far NBA
has come now he's like the bad boy look
at that smile that's the bad boy the NBA
that smile yeah
you know you'd probably be the softest
in the 90s now he's the bad boy that's
the NBA these days yeah my whole take on
Draymond Green you know you're talking
about practice
so problem with today's world is
everybody has a cell phone so that
footage should never have gotten leaked
out and they're trying to figure out who
leaked that footage because there should
be an in-house problem because if you go
back in the history of time practice
that that's not for the public
consumption that's practice so you're
gonna have problems you've had
um you know Donald for the Rams during a
practice I think it was Rams versus
Chargers you know scrimmage practice
beat him with his helmet nothing
happened to him because that's practice
those fights and that stuff happened
during practice guys don't gel and then
also when uh Draymond punched that
gentleman that that dude was talking so
much [ __ ] the the guy was coming out
saying uh and they're they're saying I
forget the guy's name that I punched
cool cool so pool's a baller so pool had
a great season last year and he resigned
he got a bunch more money guaranteed
money in the NBA they said since he
signed that deal he's been kind of
arrogant talking [ __ ] to everybody he
thinks his [ __ ] doesn't stink well dude
you're on the team with Steph Curry yeah
you got you know Thompson there you have
all these Savages you have Draymond
Green you have all these guys who've won
World Champions right and obviously he
won a world champion pool did but you
know you're you're dealing with veterans
on the team and you're walking around
real arrogant here I guess he was
talking [ __ ] for Draymond he was talking
about
just basically like he's like man what
got you the chicks at Michigan State
when you set the screens or when you
just get a few [ __ ] rebounds like
constantly talking [ __ ] to him are you
dealing with a veteran guy it's practice
the thing is it's basketball you they
not everybody has to like each other you
have a job they're professionals making
all the money so to me this shouldn't
have got out and it's weird again
Society is so different now where you
know I think Draymond Green says he's
going to take a step back you realize
that Kobe flat guys in practice all the
time flot guys you realize Michael
Jordan choked Steve Kerr
damn they're unconscious I don't mean
like a cool
blue belt Jiu Jitsu rear naked I'm
talking Jeffrey Dahmer both hands
Grandpa you know tight grip on the
throat choke little Steve Kerr
nothing ever happened guys fight all the
[ __ ] time we're talking about
practice we talk about practice it's
stupid
this shouldn't be for the public
and and also it's it's disappointing
that the the Golden State Warriors done
on his back they should go this is an
in-house matter that video should never
got out we're dealing with in-house see
you guys opening day that's all should
be done there should be no repercussions
this grown man doing grown man's yet
and for Paul the young guy mouthing off
Guy's first contract draymond's a legend
dude you know talking about All-Star
games all pro what are you really
talking about all NBA all all NBA
defensive team multiple world champion
you gotta have some respect and if you
want to mouth off like that it's okay
that he pawns the guy this isn't the end
of the world this is professional sports
and the guy did push him first so I mean
come on he did instigate it I mean
obviously Draymond Green walked up to
him and kind of like touched him with
his chest still you pushed yeah you put
there's gonna be some consequences yeah
if you push you have to expect you're
gonna be in a fight what do you think's
gonna happen yeah you push Cali Draymond
Green the bad boy the NBA what do you
think was gonna happen
you're pulling the tiger's tail and
you're trying to bite you like man we
gotta get rid of this tiger it's like no
dumbass you're pulling on stale you're
talking [ __ ] to this veteran in front of
guys embarrass him time out girls time
how shitty is at basketball all right
there's gonna be some consequences dude
for your actions
that's how things should work
that's the problem with today
what else you got well so up to
put this all and like tie a bow around
this the reason why I brought it up is
because uh Jake Paul saw the video and
Jake Paul said he'd give him he'd give
Draymond Green 10 million dollars to be
part of the most valuable promotions
pay-per-view
not enough money something not coming up
it's not enough you look at Draymond
Green's uh contract you're not gonna get
his caliber I'm sure Jake Paul knew that
too and I don't think Draymond Green's
gonna [ __ ] you know
maybe later in basketball later yeah
later if he's you know follows the Lamar
Odom route but Draymond Green's a smart
dude I doubt he will but also for Jake
Paul this is good to promote his brand
and all that [ __ ] he knows he wasn't
gonna get a yes from Draymond Green yeah
Draymond greenstone I win an NBA
championship
yeah he's good he knows how to use
social media so Islam posted about uh
Charles Oliveira because apparently it's
only two weeks away and Charles Oliver
didn't was not in Abu Dhabi yet so is
just worrying about it so do you have to
be there two weeks early though I mean
people want to adjust to whatever you
know but he's in Brazil I don't know the
time difference there can't I mean you
know yeah Abu dhabi's a different
[ __ ] planet time zone wise but from
Brazil can't be too bad for Charles
Oliveira I mean well I'll break down
that UFC
um
pay-per-view with Mike Jeff and Charles
Oliver next Monday but just the more I
look into it the more I'm leaning
towards Charles Oliver wow yeah
yeah it's hard to deny Olivia right now
he's I just think he's so dangerous
matchups obviously can get him down on
the feet Charles Oliver is definitely a
better Striker more danger Striker on
the ground shows all levere is more
dangerous so if he's constantly
threatened submissions I think
forget takedown defense you get taken
down but if you make it miserable down
there for Michael Chev and you're just
throw in all sorts of you're throwing
the kitchen sink at them where he's
constantly fighting submissions and arm
bars and triangles and darses and all
this [ __ ] and arm you know uh [ __ ]
americanas all that [ __ ] I think
eventually in a five round fight Mark
Chesney like [ __ ] this let's keep it on
the feet and then that's when Charles
oliveros at his best
I think Charles lover gets taken down
here's the other thing I know I said I'm
breaking down next week where I'll just
give you a little flavor now
this has the potential to be a great
fight if Charles de louvere wins and it
becomes game and has a good game plan
and is throwing the kitchen sink at him
and lighting them up and throwing elbows
and [ __ ] them up on the ground
because you get taken down so you have
that aspect of it or you have a you have
a really good chance if my chef wins can
be a really boring fight where mock Chev
isn't going to take any chances or the
first round to be fireworks not that my
Chef's teams like get them down control
them and you're getting four rounds of
you know much Jeff just kind of laying
on yeah
because you know in the scrambles in in
the
and all this stuff scrambles up and down
all that that's where Charles Oliver
really thrives and looks for submissions
and much Chef's team knows that like
let's just become champ and we'll move
on it's too dangerous to a fight so you
have a you have a good chance it could
be a really boring fight that would suck
yeah but if Charles Oliver wins you're
getting a great fight
all right so anyways makachev said you
know he's kind of worried because it's
two weeks before the fight and Charles
is not there yet and then Alexander
volkanovsky
actually applied to it he goes don't
worry brother I'll be there now is
volkanovsky the replacement is he the
villain is I don't know if he's an
official but I mean oh he's just saying
he'll be there he'll be there I'm sure
he would actually do it though
interesting yeah and that's why
vocalypse he wants yeah he wants to go
up to 50 yeah and then uh this is what
Charles de Bronx
suit too yeah
and he said look at his freaking
his bling dude talked yeah so he goes
you could buy an entire Favela with that
[ __ ] bracelet
calm down dad is coming hello Abu Dhabi
and he has a sign that says UFC 280 Abu
Dhabi I almost wish you put calm down
Daddy is coming but just Dad but this is
calm down father is coming this is
translation through Instagram I bet he
said Daddy yeah
yeah
uh hey buddy is that it
um
do you want a couple more what do you
want give me two more let's go okay
let's pass this and let's just go to the
food it's 10 40. I'm just chatting we've
been going 120 right now so this is
obviously [ __ ] that guy's missing an arm
that's the thing that's crazy so it's
two on one but the the two they both
have arms the one has no arm
well let me take the music off one side
so watch this oh yeah let kicks that
dude so that guy's out
and that is just one on one yep
well one on two still there's one arm
two arms right basically it's funny but
he's working on this guys with that
[ __ ] left kick
and of course he wins what a Savage yeah
it's alarming they're in basketball
shorts but whatever it's Russia how
about the two I bet when they got back
to locker room the first guy just head
kicked like in 10 seconds they got back
he's like dude what the [ __ ] were you
dude I [ __ ] hacked that guy with one
arm head kick me as soon as he got up
there man I was trying
and I think the way it looks is once you
get [ __ ] up you're out
and then I went to one-on-one yeah
because basically the guy got head
kicked they're not like hey man come on
get your [ __ ] together get back up no
because you can't do that like you're
out dude and that's one-on-one like I
was like ah [ __ ]
he basically destroyed that first guy
anyway so it was done
uh last one then this is Conor McGregor
you know before Conor McGregor smart
yeah smart my team was his PR team was
like excuse me sir here's the other
thing excuse me sir you're on the set of
Road House in Costa Rica right now chill
the [ __ ] out man they're gonna pull you
from the movie this guy was like oh [ __ ]
we don't want that he's like uh
I'll actually play you the clip of what
Connor says and it sounds weird too
because it sounds like Conor is not even
sounding like himself sounds like he's
trying to do English Acts or American
accent it's kind of here and just
getting on about that video the last
part I saw I saw you didn't understand
that I was simply acting and I I thought
you would have known brother I love my
man God bless the show
God bless the fam and God bless my man
oh yeah
okay
to Bisbee go back huh go back no go back
to the quote card so Bisping said uh
hold on if you watch the show we were
last we're having a laugh it's a [ __ ]
joke obviously there was no threats on
my end whatsoever but he kind of flipped
a lid didn't he he lost his mind anyway
kind of relaxed but he just got in
Christ there you go there's uh kind of
goes hey Mike Connor here so you didn't
understand that I was simply acting dude
I'm in a role I thought you would have
known brother I'll love my man God bless
the show God bless the fam and God bless
my man oh yeah
so weird somebody got his ears like dude
you can't threaten to show up at a guy's
house and you're on a set like I'm just
like a universal movie like we can't you
can't do that dude
at least they're being cool now yeah I
like both those guys yeah is that it
that's it just the fights you know fight
night this Saturday it's not a great
card so come see me in San Jose this
Thursday Friday Saturday instead
Thursday Friday Saturday San Jose
improvable baby uh love San Jose so San
Jose Improv is this Thursday Friday
Saturday October 13th to the 15th next
week is Salt Lake City Wise Guys one of
my favorite clubs ever shout out to
Keith the owner October 20th through the
22nd I'm in Salt Lake City and then I
end October's tour in Calgary Canada
Calgary Alberta we added a show on that
Friday so the show for the 27th the most
sold out so get your tickets now to the
Rooftop in downtown uh Calgary and then
the show on Friday we just set out so
there's tickets for the Friday show so
one show uh Thursday one show Friday
some hilarious Canadian Comics open up
for me my brother Mark Harley some of
the thick boys will be their thick boy
merch will be there tiger thick whiskey
will be there come have a shot on me
Calgary also San Jose Salt Lake City
shots on me as well the new tiger thick
the bottles are changing too we've won a
bunch of awards and taste contests so
they're adding the words to the bottles
the batch 2 is pretty lit I'm sure I'll
post it on Instagram if you if you
haven't realized we have a tiger thick
Instagram handle it's just at Tiger
thick whiskey mark
it's at Tiger thick so you'll see a
bunch of cool content on there they just
uh restocked too it's not pre-sale
anymore they restocked all of tiger
thick so go to thickboy.com to get you
some delivered straight to your door
um but San Jose I'll see you this
Thursday Friday Saturday so the fight
night got uh Lexa Grosso in my face with
Vivian you got Cub Swanson who's an
absolute Savage best find the card is
brand Roy Val versus
by far the best fight on there you got
Misha fighting Alonzo Midfield are not
mad at that
I feel sad though how do you put him on
the prelims versus Victor Henry he's
actually an underdog on that yeah Mike
Jackson the uh journalist you guys know
him for uh beating up
um CM Punk yeah
get some balls on him be journalists
full-time and fight pretty pretty badass
Mr Mike Jackson so enjoy that fellas and
ladies and then you also got I think you
got uh Deontay Wilder fighting this
Saturday too Chad is it I'm pretty sure
look it up I don't think look it up I'll
look it up right now
you got a bare knuckle
we got Devin Haney George combosis Jr
uh Friday holy crap bark yeah you're
right Deontay Wilder Robert helenius
Robert's about to get absolutely
flatlined
holy crap that's Friday right and how
about the co-main event Caleb plant
that's on Fox
you got Kayla plant go ahead and miss
that and see me in San Jose Friday
Thursday Friday Saturday kids
yeah Devin Haney George gamboso the
rematch Devin Haney to be is the best
youngster doing it so
um sweet man that's it all right go get
the new thick boy merch the Thai day
available right now thick boy get the
tiger thick sweet nectar thick boy.com
as well just click on the link you'll
see there it says tiger thick whiskey
um it's finally restocked we got the
hats the tie-dye everything thick
boy.com San Jose see you this Thursday
Friday Saturday that's it be nice each
other be safe and uh Thanks for liking
subscribing we drop a new bit on Green
Room Diaries this week on the Brennan
Shop YouTube comedy channel we just
passed the mark to get monetized on
there so that thing is booming I can't
thank you guys enough I love you guys
we're dropping new Hernandez bit for uh
Green Room Diaries as we speak Marcus
posting as we speak kiddos so go get
your merch see you in San Jose drinks on
me love you guys be nice till next time
I'm out